when jeff bezos took amazon.com public
in 1997
wall street was skeptical of the book
selling website found it in a seattle
garage
the year after amazon's ipo bezos made
forbes annual list of the 400 richest
americans for the first time
thanks to his 42 stake in the company
worth 1.6 billion dollars at the time
over two decades later amazon is one of
the largest e-commerce companies in the
world
and bezos who announced in february that
he's stepping down as ceo
has a fortune of more than 191 billion
dollars
back in 1998 bezos was number 102 on the
forbes 400 list of the richest americans
this was the first time he was on the
cover of forbes where he posed with
other icons of the dot-com bubble
of those on the cover only bezos yahoo
co-founder jerry yang
and broadcom's henry nicholas were still
among the 400 richest americans in 2020.
in 2005 a decade after the launch of
amazon.com
bezos was worth 4.8 billion dollars
this was the year amazon launched amazon
prime with its now
famous unlimited two-day shipping wall
street was skeptical
anyone would pay extra for the fast
shipping and questioned whether the
company could afford the cost of the
service
instead amazon prime was a hit and in
bazel's net worth reached 12.6 billion
dollars
after finding success with its kindle
e-reader launch
amazon took another step towards a new
frontier streaming
amazon studios launched in the fall of
2010 and would later become the first
streaming service to win a golden globe
for best tv series
beating out netflix and hulu in 2013
bezos worth 27.2 billion dollars
purchased the washington post for 250
million dollars
that same summer amazon stock hit 300
a share for the first time in 2015
bezos cracked the top five of the forbes
400 with the 47 billion dollar fortune
it was also the first year of prime day
a day of special deals amazon
announced for its 20th anniversary on
that day
shoppers ordered 34.4 million items
worldwide
that's 398 items per second
sales at amazon kept climbing and the
share price kept rising
in march of 2018 bezos then worth 112
billion dollars
toppled bill gates for the spot as the
world's richest person on the forbes
list of the world's billionaires
which brings us to the present bezos is
worth more than 190 billion dollars
and has topped our annual world's
billionaires list as the richest person
in the world for three years in a row
despite the covet 19 pandemic amazon net
sales increased by 38
in 2020 and the day amazon announced
bezos will step down
but keep his 11 stake in the company
amazon stock
closed at 3 380 a share
you